make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
is a man not entitled to take a break
from creating comic book videos for the
youtubes hello everyone
uh I have been gone for a week and it
seems like everybody is panicking like I
am dead no I am not dead I need a break
from doing this just like everybody else
and so I took my break for a week and we
are back to making videos and in this
video we are covering this story of
where Dormammu becomes The Herald of
Galactus almost a dr. strange and it's
actually amazing so here's a funny thing
when it comes to Doctor Strange as a cub
of a character for the average person it
usually seems like it's not worth the
price of admission right we're just kind
of like you know and I'll go do
something else instead uh it really
seems to feel like that like when it
when it cut because the Doctor Strange
line of comics really are for just a
particular kind of comic book fan now if
you like magic and mysticism of course
it's for you but if you're not a huge
fan of that you don't really want to
have a whole lot to do with it and
that's kind of one of the things that
that Mark Waid sort of the hits on to a
degree right like he picks up the story
and he just kind of like he's he has dr.
strange sort of musing to himself right
and it's just kind of like I have pretty
much done everything and so I'm bored
now because in reality that's the nature
of Doctor Strange comics right he's also
he's one of these weird characters he's
the master of the mystic arts and it's
kind of like I'm I know the most about
magic and you know than anybody else in
the need in the universe but it's
interesting because the question he kind
of asks here is like is there no real
adventure left anymore like is it really
nothing for me to do like is this this
is kind of it like I'm just gonna be
sitting in the house watching in the
view and waiting for something to happen
and then he suddenly met by the arrival
of a guy named Zola's now here's the
cool thing though laws is a guy who
cultural plan of the Galactus is
basically visited right like he's part
of a group called the Xerox those are
axioms and and the result is that
Galactus is literally going to consume
their world and so what his people ended
up doing was that as a mage himself they
basically took all their energies dumped
it into him and the result is that he's
been sent here now because when they
scan through the mind of Galactus to
figure out what his weakness was the
only thing they could find was earth now
this is why things were interesting
because olá shows up here believing that
earth has someone powerful enough to
defeat Goliath and they do I mean you
got the molecule man Owen Reese you've
got Franklin Richards who's really more
a kinder Galactus like they're really
more counterparts now the you know in
these days then they are like you know
one be more powerful the other oh I
guess the future version of Franklin is
basically like a counterpart to Galactus
but still like as we know as
read are the reason why Galactus sees
earth as a weakness is because of like
the totality of the heroes on it and
that's what you would need like you
would literally need like all the heroes
on earth to ban together fly to the
other side of the universe and like
defeat Galactus right but like they're
not going to because it's just the
natural role of Galactus and that's what
Zola's doesn't get is literally he just
kind of starts like getting into this
fight with Doctor Strange and of course
basically starts using his abilities to
like absorb magical energy to like
absorb all of doctor Strange's
duplicates into himself it's really one
of these things worse like every step
that dr. strange takes this guy is
powerful enough to overcome and of
course that leads into him discovering
like the various books of Doctor Strange
and absorbing all their knowledge now I
want to talk about this for a second
when it comes to magic and Marvel Comics
there was the way that things used to be
and then there's essentially kind of
like the way things are now right so the
way things used to be is that you had
essentially just like ambient energy out
there anybody who - who has a power
that's happened to like reality-warping
is harnessing the fundamental energies
of the universe is basically what it is
right so like if if the universe is clay
then they're essentially like tapping
into and manipulating that clay is
literally what they're doing when it
comes to like telepathy it's tapping
into the ambient energies basically
tapping into the ability to access the
astral plane more or less you know
access the realm where like thoughts go
- as they pass from one location to the
next and then in turn you know harness
those thoughts to do whatever it is that
you want to do control them wipe them
out of somebody's head whatever the case
is then there's the way that they exist
now right so like magic was it was just
kind of energy that was there and you
could manipulate it in Ultimates volume
2 issue number 100 by Al Ewing what he
said was that magic actually never used
to exist it wasn't until the various you
know the multiverse was destroyed and
recreated and destroyed and recreated
what it was destroyed and remade for the
fifth time did that version of eternity
had basically like brought magic into
the main Marvel Universe and said okay
magic is here now and people can use it
of course that multiverse was destroyed
and recreated again but the fact remains
like that's what magic started being
brought in and people had the ability to
access it so we know like of all the
different versions of the multiverse
that have ever existed there was never a
dr. strange until you got to the fifth
version again it's a little bit of a
little bit of a historical thing there
but the fact remains that what you have
here in this day and age is essentially
just like a wide array of different
people tapping into a wide array of
different powers now that was always the
case but having somebody come along
who's more power
dr. strange really highlights two things
one that of course there are people out
there who can use magic in a more adept
way than dr. strange and two dr. strange
is the sorcerer supreme in name only now
that's the indication that's put off
here that's the the basis behind like
what's being told because basically the
skies can let you have all these forms
of magical energy here you have all
these things that you could use why
don't you just use them all now what
this does is it kind of moves into the
second part of that discussion that says
okay the difference here is that we're
Doctor Strange could absorb all these
forms of energy into himself all these
magical principles and then use them for
his own ends who knows what kind of
chaos would would erupt because of it
and so that's the the true nature of
Doctor Strange yes he could acquire
absolute power is it a good idea No now
again this kind of flies in the face of
a lot of stories we've seen before right
like dr. strange basically go into
senators market and then bartering 100%
of his soul for 100% of his power or at
least trying but we only know that level
at least we do know dr. strange only
does that in like the most extreme
circumstances right like the Beyonder
comes back and wants to attack earth
okay well then he'll do whatever he
needs to do in order to make that happen
but under normal circumstance you can't
do that at the same time it's also
Zola's not really understanding the
nature of Galactus it's his role in the
cosmos right I mean it's just one of
those sakes if Galactus comes rolling up
on your place and it's gonna start like
consuming your entire planet sorry about
your luck that's just the way it goes
nice knowing you're like this it's
basically you know just like free while
you can but it's the role of Galactus
he's a fundamental part of that part of
the universe and so again like we know
that from a wide array of different
stories but of course Zola's doesn't
they're so basically channeling all
these magical energies he literally
opens a portal in the main Marvel
Universe and whisks calacas away to like
the depths of the mystic realms what
this means is Galactus is now in the
realm of like Dormammu and he's in the
realm of like nightmare he's in the
realm of like all these basic mystical
here these these mystical forces that
are out there and there's no guess as to
what like there's no telling what in the
world is gonna happen and that's what
dr. strange kind of freaks out about
right like like Galactus is a being of
pure science right like he serves a
purpose it is i am a being who travels
around the cosmos and i serve two
purposes the first is that I consume
planets that can sustain life sustaining
energy so that the Celestials cannot
plant their eggs and like every single
planet across the cosmos and overrun the
universe and I also do this because I'm
a gatekeeper all right if I die
Abraxas comes out and Abraxas will
basically wipe
the entire multiverse those you guys hit
ever who don't know about Abraxas he's
essentially just like the like the the
representation of the multiverse is
destruction right like there was a story
in the 2000s where Galactus died where
he was allowed to die basically was kind
of like hey look if I die terrible
things will happen and it was allowed to
die or he was allowed to die and then in
turn like basically find out that like
Abraxas this being that represents
destruction in the multiverse breaks out
of this kind of prison he's always been
in and then he in turn starts traveling
around like the multiverse killing every
version of Galactus that he finds so I
did it was it was kind of crazy was a
pretty wonky story but suffice it to say
a practice is a Abraxas insanely
powerful like he's it's it's nuts how
powerful he is but to take someone like
that like Galactus and then throw him
into the the mystic depths there's no
telling what would happen that's exactly
what strange says and so what he gets in
there with all those magical arms and an
armory and so on and so forth then
suddenly he's met by like this giant
stampede of people who were I guess
beings who were all just fleeing for
their lives because Galactus like the
first thing he does is start consuming
like energy off of one of these planets
but I just starts doing exactly what
Galactus is doing now here's a funny
thing strain shows up here is as hey
look man you can't necessarily do that
now the fact that Galactus addresses him
directly is a little bit astounding and
that's kind of one of the funny things
that Wade talks about here right because
we know from from Marvel Comics Galactus
never usually addresses just like a
being like a normal person he doesn't
really care he's like I mean none why
would I care about I care enough to talk
to you you know one there's nothing you
could probably tell me that would that
would interest me intellectually right I
mean you're no Reed Richards and two
like you're not really powerful enough
to stop me or challenge me so why do you
like here but the lock just literally
addresses him and is like why am I here
so we're just kind of like okay Galactus
is trying to get a feel for surroundings
trying to figure out like what's going
on why he's here all that kind of good
stuff
not only that what's happened is he's
basically been like sent to a particular
place in the in the the depths of the
mystic realm and then bound inside of a
prison and so he has like these little
small planetoids here and there but
those aren't enough to do anything for
him and so what he basically does is
like break out of his prison and into
like took greater depth then like the
first person he runs into her the first
thing he runs into is a missing hawk or
F now mr. Hawk gorath is is what's
referred to as the beasts of paint but
there's no real history to go on here
because this is the first time he's ever
been seen and then he dies because it's
like it's like okay
ah so that guy's gone but what this is
this is actually Mark Waid proving a
very
point when it comes to Galactus as a
character is largely assumed he just
absorbs a life the the ambient energies
of a life-sustaining planet and then
moves on what this actually confirms is
something that we I guess maybe I always
kind of knew in the back of our heads
but never really thought about that
Galactus can absorb energy off of beams
and that's exactly what happens here
right like this beast of pain goes to
attack Galactus and then basically shows
him like I have a huge amount of energy
stored inside of me and it's her and
Galactus absorbs it all out of them now
it could very well just be that this guy
is kind of like a conduit for magical
energy which means like he actually
stores that energy inside of him as
opposed to being like Doctor Strange
where he just reaches out and touches it
and and and harnesses it it could be
that way we don't really know but
whatever the basis behind him is all
this energy that he possesses at his
disposal Galactus absorbs it and that's
when Doctor Strange begins to realize
that a very dangerous thing is happening
with Galactus going through and
absorbing all these magical energies
that exists either in planets or in
people inside this universe that what
he's basically doing is tapping into a
source of energy that he's not really
familiar with and that even dr. strange
himself doesn't really know what effect
it'll have right I mean like to what
this is is like a lot just going out
it's like you going out and eating like
a standard Western diet every day right
like 50% protein 25% fats and like 25%
carbs or something along those lines you
know 30% fats and and you know 20% carbs
or whatever whatever the case says you
going out and in turn like consuming a
standard Western diet and then just
suddenly jumping into like a random diet
like a like an exotic diet with no
indication of what it'll do to you right
like it's it's the best example I could
think of but that's basically yet here
is literally what's going on Galactus is
form is is predicated on consuming
life-sustaining energies in a universe
he was born into so he was born for that
purpose he was not born for the purpose
of consuming magical energy who knows
what kind of situation that's gonna
create so of course dr. strange binds
Galactus and is able to do it for a
pretty good chunk of time but again
we're talking about Galactus so the
concern that he has is I'm not going to
be able to keep this guy bound forever
like eventually he's going to break out
and of course like Galactus begins to
you and then - when his binds
re-established again and we're met with
the arrival of Clea now Clea is a
character that we haven't talked about
ever and we've never had a reason to
because she's never she hasn't appeared
in a very long time
anyway the basis behind this really
actually goes into the origin of two
beings
boom our
and Dormammu now back in the old strange
tale comics when when Dormammu first
popped up what you got was the the the
origin of his character shortly after
around that time we also learned about a
group called the fall team now the fall
team FAL Ti and II this is a group that
existed in another dimension and was
naturally adept at wielding magical
energy the issue is that Dormammu and
Umar wanted like physical pleasures more
or less and of course that was kind of
banished because they were beings
composed of like spiritual form and so
because that they basically ended up
killing a senator I think killing their
their creator and then in turn they like
were banished to the Dark Dimension
now the Dark Dimension at the time was
ruled by a guy named King Omar he was
like a warlord or something like that
anyway basically like Umar and Dormammu
showed up in the Dark Dimension and
we're kind of like okay so like this is
our place now and usually like
subterfuge and being deceptive they
basically started to use King anar as a
way to essentially like doom his own
people the merch at least I'm pretty
sure that's how it's pronounced mercs I
think it's mhm u u RK s I think it's how
you pronounced or how you spell it but
basically this was a group that like was
a normal inhabitant of the Dark
Dimension
and then in turn could also use magical
energy what ended up happening here is
that with with Dormammu and Umar taking
over and then Dormammu basically going
into his fall to uniform which is his
energy based form and then umar
maintaining her human form this led to a
more engaging in a affair of sorts with
one of the servants of Dormammu
and this basically led to the birth of
Clea and so Clea is technically the
rightful heir to the throne of the Dark
Dimension ah so think of think of like
katana for mortal kombat basically um
but she's technically the rightful heir
from to the to the Dark Dimension but
she doesn't really take it because door
mom who currently rules it so unless she
was able to master I guess muster a
sizable force that was powerful enough
to take out Dormammu in his own
dimension which is probably never gonna
happen in turn like she would his
basically kind of reside there now she
and Doctor Strange teamed up a couple
times and then like the second or third
time that happened they fell in love she
became a student of Doctor Strange and
then eventually he married her she
became his wife so now she's his ex-wife
so but basically just take it as you
know his ex-wife is here in order to
help him which is kind of weird but what
they end up doing is basically saying
like what we need is an alliance of
people like we basically need an
alliance of magic wielders out there
some of the most powerful people in
existence in order to like get rid of
Galactus and banished him from here and
so that's when you bring in Omar now
Umar is synonymous
deception right I mean that's the nature
of her character she's the sister of
Dormammu is one of these things were
like she's always trying to like topple
her brother and take his place or she's
really kind of wants to be second place
and just wants to sort of manipulate
things behind the scenes her schemes and
motivations really never make sense to
anybody but herself and she's insanely
powerful but it's one of the funny
things that we're seeing here is it like
Galactus is more powerful and that's
kind of the cool thing is because what
they're doing is they're they're
literally going through and like they're
like Galactus is kind of being ravaged
by the very energies he's consuming and
so it seems like one of these things
where the more energy consumes the more
seems to consume him now the reality of
this is Doctor Strange looks at that and
says no no it's not really that I mean I
guess he is kind of being consumed book
a lot dis is changing and the reason why
is because Galactus is actually a being
of pure energy that's one of the things
to bear in mind Galactus doesn't really
have a true physical form he did at one
point but when he was born into the main
Marvel Universe as Galactus he was born
as a being of pure energy that's why it
is whenever Galactus shows up on the
doorstep of a races planet and he's
gonna consume their planet he's a mirror
to them right so like the scrolls will
see a scroll version of Galactus the
Kree will see a Kree version of Galactus
but it's the outfit he wears on the fact
that he's there to consume their planet
that makes him so terrifying now of
course we found that out in the trial of
Reed Richards way back in the 1980s
whenever it wasn't that story came out
but the overall just behind this is that
what's happening is the normal energies
that make up Galactus the energy is of a
positive universe basically like the
main Marvel Universe are slowly being
replaced by these exotic energies he's
consuming right so it's like having a
bottle of water and then dropping some
iodine inside right like some die of
comes some kind it's gonna start to
permeate out and then eventually change
the water if you put enough in there and
that's what's happening here Galactus is
essentially being poisoned by magical
energy and so what ended up happening is
Doctor Strange which is okay fine in
this case like we can't have you running
around a consuming like all these
life-sustaining planets because we have
no idea what effect it's gonna have on
you like in the extreme if you get to
the wrong one so I will do two things
one I will basically become your new
Herald go out and try to find a planet
that is uninhabited and two I will try
to make sure the uninhabited planet I
find will keep you sustained but will
not continue to poison you the way that
like all these other planets have been
consuming you and that's why it's kind
of a crazy thing because Galactus is
just sort of falling apart
more or less
and so what is up happening here is you
end up having like Dormammu who's
basically visited like by Mesa hog or F
and it's kind of like hey look like
there's this crazy powerful being who's
consuming everything you have to stop
him and that's what we end up finding
out Dormammu is already aware of
Galactus like he's already aware of the
power Galactus has it he's already aware
of like what he's capable of and like
he's already making moves against
Galactus to be able to like defeat him
and that's kind of the crazy thing here
is because we're Doctor Strange is sort
of hopping around and going from world
to world trying to find different
locations you have like the forces of
Umar who are traveling around and they
actually end up running up on nightmare
now nightmare is actually a cool guy so
in Marvel Comics the way this works is
that whenever you lay down and go to
sleep if you have a nightmare those
nightmares feed the actual nightmare
dimension which powers the guy nightmare
but they're also there's also a
potential that for them to be kind of
fed back to you in the extreme and
that's where the reasons why nightmares
is really considered to be like in
immortal and indestructible being so
long as beings exist and they can dream
the nightmare can exist because they
will have nightmares the only way to
really to get nightmare to a point where
he can be defeated is to wipe out all
sentient life but you'd have to
essentially blink out the universe which
would kill him anyway because you mean
literally it's it's the dreams of like
all beings in existence and then
potentially the dreams in the future so
like or at least the nightmares of
people in the future it's really weird
and it's really finicky but basically if
they got nightmare on their side well it
may not necessarily be enough to like
overpower Galactus in his entirety and
like destroy him because he's just so
amped up with all this magical power it
would certainly be enough to create like
some a havoc and so we're basically
Doctor Strange ends up finally locating
a planet and then grabs Galactus and
brings him back what the end of finding
out is there's all these small little
instances of people getting in their way
of trying to like slow Galactus down and
eventually he ends up having to invoke
his power and sorry attacking these guys
was of course begins to depower him a
little bit more now eventually we end up
finding out too like once they get to
this planet and like the lot just goes
to consume it immediately right off the
bat we end up finding out something is
wrong that this plan has been tainted
and that's what we end up finding out
Dormammu was the one behind it that
Dormammu is the new Herald of Galactus
and that Dormammu tampered the tamper
with this planet so that when Galactus
who went to consume it it would amp him
up but it would also twist him and screw
him up and basically become kind of a
servant to Dormammu but at the same time
like Dormammu becoming a Herald of
Galactus the other half of
is that when dr. strange sits down that
says okay so like something else has to
be going on here right like yes Dormammu
is very very powerful but like by
himself at least it seems to be the
indication by himself der mom who's not
necessarily powerful enough to stop
Galactus now we actually don't know this
we can't really argue either way because
the reality of this is that they've
never met and there are two beings from
two distinctly different dimensions I
mean I guess you can find some way to
kind of you know move the pieces around
and cook the book so that some argument
can be made but the reality is that like
we've never seen this happen before
we've never seen a full-on conflict
between Galactus and Dormammu
and so it's really kind of creating a
narrative and creating a standard and
saying okay so like you know
definitively Dormammu is not more power
is no more powerful than Galactus right
like there's these like Galactus is more
powerful than your mom who essentially
like that's really kind of what's being
said here and that the other the other
way to kind of manipulate this the other
kind of power that was needed came from
Mephisto as it always does but basically
the gist behind this is that the
alliance that was formed between to her
mom who and Mephisto that wasn't so
basically mean is that Dormammu would
conquer planets and continue to expand
his his reign his Kingdom right like
outside of the Dark Dimension and into
other places in the mystic realms and
then like expand his kingdom but every
single world that is consumed and the
people who perished basically expand
Mephisto realm now is this is kind of
the crazy thing
Mephisto doesn't really take souls in
the traditional sense Mephisto is vers
like his his section of Hell is is
essentially like expanded by people who
sold their souls for some particular
deed right like whether it was money or
like success or power or something along
those lines but it basically bargained
with Mephisto not realizing they're like
when everything was done Mephisto would
take their soul to his realm ah that's
that's really what his version of hell
is Kazan for it's not just everyone who
dies just automatically goes to her
Mephisto is that up presumably it's
those individuals that he probably made
pacts with which he could I mean
presumably Mephisto could use his almost
infinite power to show up and it
basically appear to every single person
who's basically dying on the planet at
the same time and saying like you know I
can I can do this I can basically you
know I can save you all you have to do
is say yes and they say okay like they
they basically make a deal with Mephisto
and then when they all end up dying
anyway and they show up in his realm and
he's like you know they're like well I
thought you were gonna save us and it's
like I did I saved you for my realm you
know and then just BAM leave him there
some along those lines I mean presumably
he could do that and he's almost
infinitely powerful but that's basically
what's going on
in mephisto are now working in tandem
together and that door mom who is now
the Herald of Galactus taking him from
planet to planet and basically showing
him all the best worlds to feed on
presumably all the worlds of door mama
wants to go after but it's actually
pretty beast like I'm pretty excited
about this like I want to see him fight
that's what I want to see like Galactus
versus Dormammu okay so continuing on
with our videos on Doctor Strange here's
the thing I didn't even realize it was
gonna do that well right it was just
like Doctor Strange it was like Galactus
to me store mama and then you guys went
crazy on that video which I guess is
something everybody always wanted to see
was like dr. strange meeting Dormammu
like what happens when these two beings
of crazy power encounter one another in
this video they fight and it's the
coolest thing it's amazing I am I am so
excited about this okay there so
initially this picks up in Mephisto
realm right and for those of you guys
who were just now kind of joining this
essentially Galactus have been banished
to the realm of magic right so like all
these magical worlds and things like
that literally people were panicking and
fleeing right like Doctor Strange went
there to try to solve the problem but
couldn't really deal with it and then
halfway through all this madness
Dormammu hit like basically bombarded
Galactus with essentially what was like
dark magical energy and kind of
transformed him into what Dormammu
considered to be a Herald and so we
ended up finding out Mephisto had
basically a pact with up with Dormammu
insofar as as long as Galactus was in
that realm all those individuals hovels
beings who would die would be symptom
oficers round and then of course with
all those beings basically being killed
off it could allow Dormammu to to spread
his influence outside his own dimension
and into like the greater magical
dimension as a whole and so what this
does is get a little more nuanced in a
little more into that the funny thing
about this is that with Doctor Strange
trying to rationalize with Dormammu in
saying hey look man you have no idea
what you're doing
the magical barriers are basically being
weakened one of the things that Marvel's
established over the years and they're
they're comics when it comes to magical
energy is there's this kind of invisible
barrier that separates the magical
dimensions from like the regular Marvel
Universe right so I mean it's almost
like closing a door right I mean it's
what keeps the dimension of Dormammu the
dark dimension from just like flowing
over into the main universe right it's
like a it's like a kind of invisible
gate that keeps everything separated and
everything locked away what's happening
is that with Galactus his presence in
this universe is essentially opened a
door and by virtue of doing that allows
magical energy to flow into the main
Marvel Universe
disrupt everything accordingly so
science really kind of goes out the door
and in fact science and magic are sort
of blending together now we know that
happens in places like Asgard the
difference is that has kind of been
mastered and has been contained here in
in the main Marvel Universe none of
that's happening is just kind of running
amok unchecked with no one really
understanding how to do it but the cool
thing about this is Dormammu whose
argument is I can use Galactus as a
means to essentially walk through this
doorway and enter into the main Marvel
Universe and we know that if he
successfully did that it would be a
catastrophe right because like one of
the things that has been established
over the course of of dr. Strange's
comics and Marvel is that if Dormammu at
full strength were to enter into the
main Marvel Universe pretty much nobody
could stop him because his power is just
so extreme and absolute that it's almost
completely immutable and indestructible
now that's within his own realm that
Dark Dimension even showing up in the
main Marvel Universe it would be extreme
but the funny thing is that Mark Waid
kind of rebuffs that right and will
actually find out why here in a little
bit but it kind of rebuffs that and
actually says it's not really that way
when it comes to Dormammu but the funny
thing about this is that with everything
happening the way that it is the magical
barrier basically flowing into the
scientific barrier it's creating all
kinds of problems and all kinds of chaos
and that's the funny thing is because
Dormammu is by his definition and
exceedingly arrogant guy and so when he
looks at Galactus and he says I've
imbued him with dark energy he's now
mice through all I control him and then
in turn orders Galactus Galactus blows
him off and he's easily like I'm
nobody's Harold now one of the questions
people would ask is why hasn't Galactus
acknowledged Dormammu up to this point
remember when it comes to Galactus is a
being if he doesn't really consider you
someone of significance he'll just
ignore you he just won't pay any
attention to you right I mean you're an
ant and the cosmic scope of things so
you know why would you pay attention to
the going ons of an ant that's how he
functions but it's kind of crazy here
because wind or mom who literally powers
up all of his energy and then goes to
attack Galactus Galactus absorbs all the
power of Dormammu into himself and then
absorbs doom Dormammu himself in the
Galactus and then goes forward is like
this holy holy powerful entity and
that's the fight it happens that fast
and I know it seems a little
anticlimactic but this is a powerful
statement because what it's saying is
that even in his own realm even in the
Dark Dimension the power of Dormammu is
dwarfed by the power of Galactus and
that's bold
that's a bold statement to make people
will look at that and say that's
ridiculous there's no way Galactus could
overpower Dormammu but that's kind of a
silly statement to make because I've
never fought before so there's no reason
to believe that couldn't be the case
Galactus is right now in possession of
all his power cosmic and all that all
the power of Dormammu it's crazy like
he's he's on he's on a scale of power
that he's never experienced before and
even dr. strange is like so we're
basically screwed like there's really
nothing we can do here like we're
talking about a guy who already had the
power of Galactus right like the ability
like create life and all that kind of
stuff and now he's got all those all the
magical energy of Dormammu
which amplifies his power even more it's
crazy how capable and how powerful he's
become here now the other half of this
is that realizing what it was Dormammu
said in making reference to Mephisto dr.
strange takes office is fine we have to
go find the fist so we have to talk him
and figure out what's going on and when
the two of them talk together the
discussion of dr. stranger at least the
argument he makes here is look the the
boundary between magic and science are
going away and is permeating the
entirety of the universe which includes
your realm so it's only a matter of time
before your realm will be subjugated by
whatever all this chaos is that happens
to unfold ah so either you can be on
board or you can Harrison everybody else
and Mephisto response is no my realm is
fine now of course the way this is done
it's obvious Mephisto realizes his realm
would be in jeopardy like his dimension
would probably perish but he doesn't
side with dr. strange immediately
instead what he says is I will freak Lia
and Umar the sister of the sister of
Dormammu I will do that but so long as
you make a bargain with me now this is
dangerous because remember when it comes
to Mephisto he takes the souls of those
he makes bargains with and is usually a
catch of some sort right so like let's
say for example that you are a person
who like lost your legs you would say if
you give me back my legs I will serve as
like your Ghost Rider or something along
those lines
Mephisto would say okay I will give you
your legs back in and you can be my
Ghost Rider and so he'll give you your
legs and then he'll in turn he'll take
away your ability to feel it right so
like you have your legs back but you
still can't use them or he would give
you your legs back and then take away
your arms or something along those lines
there's a catch to it and so basically
there's no real benefit for you to be in
league with him and then when you die he
gets your soul so with dr. strange he
basically says okay I will make a pact
with you you can call me for you can
call me up for a favor at some point and
I will be bound to you to fulfill this
this this need that you have this favor
whatever it is you ask of me I will do
it just freak Lia and free Umar and the
reason why is because it was clear being
the ex-wife of dr. strange and Umar
being the sister of Dormammu they're
exceedingly powerful and dr. strange
needs all the powerful allies at his
side that he can possibly get and that's
what he does he sends you know
umar and Clea into the you know really
into like the magical dimensions
says get as many allies as you possibly
can they end up going to visit a visit
nightmare they end up going to visit
despair too insanely powerful beings
right like nightmares power is extremely
he's powered by like all the nightmares
of sentient beings right so his power is
extreme and we're previously he ignored
Clea and Umar said I'm not having
anything to do with this when like
Dormammu as powerful as he is was
defeated the nightmares like okay I'm on
your side and that's a testament to how
powerful door mom who is that's one of
the things to bear in mind among those
who are familiar with like the magical
side of things Dormammu is terrifying
because like his power is so incredibly
vast and so so wild and so in addition
to that you have Doctor Strange who
actually goes in pleads to eternity and
to to the Living Tribunal and this is
kind of cool because when when when
situations like this happened the
argument of Doctor Strange is as a
living tribunal you exist to maintain a
cosmic balance eternity like you're
basically the like the representation of
all life in the universe of like the
entire space of the universe makes up
you guys have to aid us and the response
of eternity is no I will continue on no
matter what form the universe takes
magic will permeate in the science and
everything will go into disarray but my
form will still remain there's no reason
for me to act here and the Living
Tribunal judges in agreement and he says
this is just the new cosmic order of
things that magic will blend with
science and then like that'll be it and
like it'll find a new harmony but
there's no imbalance here there's no
reason for me to judge ah therefore we
are both out of this and this is a huge
blow for Doctor Strange because if
either eternity or even the Living
Tribunal stepped in fight would be over
like that
it'd be done it was just a wave of their
hands Galactus goes back to normal to
the way he was before he gets whisked
back into the main Marvel Universe and
the story ends and that's basically it
but the fact that they choose not to act
means that essentially that like as far
as like the magical nature of things and
even the universe itself they're screwed
like they're basically kind of on their
own and and seemingly there's no real
way for them to overcome this or at
least that appears to be the case and so
what Doctor Strange ends up doing is
actually calling together pretty much a
whole host of the various magical and
demonic entities out there right so you
got Daimon Hellstrom you've got brother
voodoo you've got magic you've got a
Scarlet Witch we don't really talked
about Daimon Hellstrom he's basically
the son of the devil he was actually
kind of a cool character for a little
while my oldest never really knew what
to do with him outside of his first
appearances but basically is all these
various magical beings that are out
there and dr. Strange's response is okay
well I mean we know we're not
necessarily
as equipped as we could be right because
I mean despite the power they have here
even with Scarlet Witch she's not
channeling the power of C'thun she's not
like House of M House of M level but
what you have here is is where dr.
strange like okay so this is all we have
um that's fine we'll do the best that we
can he basically gets a response from
like everyone you know where he's kind
of like okay
our numbers are not that high but we you
know I kind of wish they could be uh
then it's like okay well then allow us
to help so what we get here are the
Inhumans we get we get Valkyrie murmur a
lot of this this actually takes place it
takes place before the war of realms we
have Nova we have like basically all
these different beings like the Silver
Surfer gladiator of the Shiar Imperial
Guard you've got like like The
Incredible Hulk you have pretty much all
the heavy hitters in Marvel you've got a
lot of heavy hitters like a lot of
powerful guys here I think even Captain
universe is here and so Doctor Strange
is actually kind of heartened by this
you know because it's like okay so like
we have a chance to basically win here
like we've got some very very powerful
people hopefully it'll be enough we
stand a much better chance than we did
before so where the questions asked what
do we do his response is keep a tight
formation keep the faith and above all
do not die okay so continuing on with
Doctor Strange this is I mean this
story's getting nuts see here's the
thing guys like here's here's why this
is such a big deal right because you
look at someone like Galactus and you
say okay so Galactus have the power
cosmic what does that mean well the
power cosmic is just kind of a hand wavy
explanation for why Galactus can do what
he does right it's basically the power
of a universe more or less I mean he was
born from a previous universe into the
new one he's just kind of been around
ever since but then you have someone
like Dormammu and Dormammu is part of
the Fall teen I think it is is is like
crazy powerful right I mean it's one of
those things like in the old Doctor
Strange stories and a lot has changed
since then but in the old Doctor Strange
stories it was large least it was
largely assumed and then I guess more
recently verified that if Dormammu ever
showed up in the main Marvel Universe at
full power like virtually nobody would
be able to stop him now this really
seems to answer that question and say
like Galactus could basically defeat him
Galactus could be the one to stop him
could overpower him again like I think
it's kind of debatable I mean it is you
know I love the way the story's being
written and I like what Mark Waits doing
but I mean this Dormammu though I mean
you know like a lot just is powerful but
like Dormammu is exceedingly powerful
and so with this story unformed the way
it is what this ends up doing is it
actually ends up picking up with satanic
now satanic is a character he's appeared
like
50 some odd times maybe like 55 56 times
he hasn't shown up a whole lot of times
in in in Marvel Comics he debuted back
in in 1968 with Doctor Strange number
174 um I've heard tale that like he was
referenced about two or three years
before that I know if it's true or not
and I was never really that consistent
of a reader with Doctor Strange so I
wouldn't be able to I wouldn't know if
that's true or not and I'm not gonna go
back and read you know all the Doctor
Strange comics from 1966 to 1968 to find
out it's not really that important to me
but it's a tannish was created by
Dormammu and the idea behind this is
that say tanagers is one of those
characters of Doctor Strange can invoke
now this is one of the things you have
to understand when it comes to Stephen
strange with his powers of course he has
no real power unto himself he invokes
the powers of others but the issue was
satanic unlike the vishanti or unlike
likes in Iraq or any of those other
demons that he basically summons energy
from say tannish is is like a benevolent
being round he's a malevolent being
there we go not benevolent he's kindly
and a good guy he's a he's a malevolent
force and so if Doctor Strange summons
the power of satanic what it does is it
would open a means by which satanic
could show up on earth and then he would
try to he would try to show up here and
then unleash all kinds of problems I
mean there have been groups like the
sons a satanic order like a cult from
back in the day but you're talking about
an exceedingly powerful being here now
if this was any other situation I would
just kind of roll with it and say wow
this is incredible but because of the
fact that you're talking about Galactus
having already defeated Dormammu who in
turn created satanic there's no real
reason to but to see this as kind of
like a shocking thing I mean it is
shocking in so far as if you're a reader
of Doctor Strange Galactus is basically
just like steamrolling the most powerful
characters that we've ever seen in a
Doctor Strange comic shy of like the
cosmic entities and like The Living
Tribunal right so like all the demonic
forces that are out there Galactus is
just like wrecking them all right so I
mean this this is almost kind of like a
mini Doctor Strange version of like
Secret Wars right like the Beyonder show
up and just kill all the cosmic entities
that's really what this is now this
doesn't have to build up to it so it's
not nearly as grandiose in scope but
that's basically what's happening here
and that's why people are really
starting to freak out and really
starting to panic because when satanic
seems to be winning Galactus somebody
just absorbs all of his energy unto
himself and then can
satanic and when that happens there's no
one really left to stop it right like
seitan is kind of like their ace in the
hole at least for all the superheroes
who were there now of course Doctor
Strange has been out of the picture for
the most part and you know following up
from the last issue we know that it's
because he's basically gathering a lot
of the superheroes that are out there
and bringing who he can to this
particular fight but the reality of this
is that this is just sort of a stopgap
measure you know this feels a lot like
Infinity Gauntlet that's one of the
things that I was thinking when I was
reading this it feels a lot like
Infinity Gauntlet right like you have
the main Infinity Gauntlet story
Thanos gets the gauntlet itself and then
basically Adam warlock uses all those
superheroes as cannon fodder in order to
more or less distract a nose to get them
all arrogant and all I kind of good
stuff and in a moment of hubris he would
send the Silver Surfer in to steal the
gauntlet and and basically save the day
and it didn't work but that really seems
to be what's happening here right
because even Stephen strange says that
you know when he's being talked to by by
all these various individuals what's
basically happening is it's kind of like
okay so like these guys can't win right
like Carol Danvers cannot defeat
Galactus and she never could ah like
gladiator cannot defeated Galactus none
of these guys can defeat the like to see
Incredible Hulk I mean there's no one
here that would really stand a chance
but the way the mark way does this is
particularly interesting right because
one of the things that we get here is
the voice of black ball now we kind of
have to make the assumption that this
takes place before the events of death
of Inhumans right because during the
death of the Inhumans story Black Bolt
lost his voice he can't do is quasi
sonic scream anymore and so when he's
like shouting and screaming at Galactus
letting it all out Galactus is sort of
stunned and that does make sense Mark
Waid is is running with Black Bolt but
also kind of ignoring the entire
continuity as we've seen it before now
and truth he can get away with it I mean
people kind of give me a hard time for
making fun of Black Bolt but like he
sucks Black Belts powers back in the day
he used to be able to scream and I he
could shatter planets with a screen
right I mean and the idea was like like
if he really really belted right if he
just if he just like let that note fly
who knows what it was that he could
achieve but over the years in Marvel his
powers have basically been dropped off
right I mean the most powerful version
of his character was actually in house
of him when he whispered and like
annihilated square miles of
land right so when you're talking about
him like in the main Marvel Universe now
well of course he's far weaker than he
ever was you know especially having lost
his voice but even before that he was
weaker than he was in the past uh having
this Display of power
blackball hasn't had this kind of power
in a long long time so in terms of of
how this fits into continuity I kind of
feel like Mark ways the sort of grabbing
things I'm filling it in I think this
has really done more for the purpose of
just showing us how dire things are and
the fact that like everybody's giving it
their all
blackbolt does a pretty decent job but
at the end of the day he's defeated and
consumed by Galactus just like everybody
else and that's when people really begin
to panic here because with Galactus
consuming the power of Black Bolt and
then having this sort of quasi sonic
scream what it does is it starts
emanating all this this quasi sounding
energy out and just begins to sort of
ripple and in effect the boundaries of
of science and magic right so it's like
this like basically a shadow a
shattering glass right a black ball were
to like scream and shatter a planet
that's basically what's happening with
the barriers between these magical
dimensions and reality itself right
because normally everything is
compartmentalized normally you'd like
the I mean we kind of used the example
of a house pretty consistently when it
comes to the when it comes to these you
know dimensions and things like that but
if the house if a house is like the main
Marvel Universe and like the closet is
Asgard and like the master bedroom is
you know the Dark Dimension where
Dormammu resides and all that kind of
stuff normally those doors are always
closed and so long as those doors are
closed no dimension can bleed into the
other what Galactus is done here is
blown the doors off right so it's just
like everything's just bleeding into
everything else right it's just it's
just mixing iodine or make something
like a dye with water everything just
kind of jumbles all together and so what
you end up getting here is is the
character of gladiator jumping in now
quell arc in reality should never stand
a chance against Galactus he's powerful
but he ain't that powerful classic hell
arc is like classic Cal arc from back in
the day probably from yet from from back
in the day like in the 80s and the 90s
he was very powerful these days not
really and that's one of the things that
you see and and in reality if that of
the Inhumans hadn't happened I would
look at this and say I think that what
Mark Waid is doing is trying to bring
the characters back to the roles they
had before they lost a lot of their
power and and that khana seems to be the
case here but again
I think we're really just kind of
looking at it from the perspective of
like things are popping off and this is
how crazy it is right but because of
everything that's going on the the Shiar
Imperial Guard basically the Special
Forces group that Cal arc leads the
gladiator leads they all kind of go
charging in all these characters all go
charging in and for the most part it
doesn't really make any difference at
all none of it really matters and that's
when we end up learning the plan of dr.
strange that much like much like Adam
warlock from Infinity Gauntlet what
Doctor Strange has come to the
realization of is that given enough time
Galactus will see me it seems like he
will destroy himself the problem is we
don't know exactly how that will play
out right because you're talking about
uncharted territory here you're talking
about a cosmic entity who's left the
main Marvel Universe gone into into a
magical dimension and is essentially
consuming everything right I mean like
all the superheroes are for the most
part in the process of being consumed
right like Dormammu sister is being
consumed me Incredible Hulk all these
guys they're all being consumed by
Galactus if they have any real power of
measure that Galactus can use to bolter
his own abilities right he's essentially
gone insane and so with with Doctor
Strange running up on him he basically
comes to the realization that what
Galactus is doing he's it's like he's
overeating right he's reaching critical
mass because remember Galactus is pure
energy and so what's been going on here
is that with him absorbing all this
energy he's reaching an unstable state
but he's basically reaching a point by
which he'll just kind of explode with
all those energy going outward there's
no indication of what will happen next
and so Doctor Strange running up on him
goes to attack him and when he seemingly
injures Galactus or the very least
appears to destroy him what results is
that everything is seemingly wiped away
the Doctor Strange is a stuck out in
this kind of white void of everything
with no clue what it is that he's done
or how bad he's screwed everything up
it's really cool like I'm really really
digging this okay so I am currently in a
hotel right now and the reason why I'm
in a hotel will be made apparent on my
vlog new channel but we are recording
the audio for Doctor Strange technically
I'm supposed to be on vacation like
really I am but like yeah the video I
had scheduled came out today so in the
the last video on Doctor Strange we had
talked about how like a lot just
basically consumed Dormammu right like
he basically like taking over the
energies of Dormammu and then sucked him
into himself right and this basically
elevated Galactus to like a whole new
level of power right he was essentially
like God little animals is kind of
interesting if there was an eternity for
the the
dimension right for all the the space
that makes up the various magical
dimensions then it would have been
Galactus after he had consumed that he
was just so astronomically powerful and
so the result was that dr. strange
handled all of his magical energy into a
single hit and then attacked the lactis
and when he did the belief was that he
destroyed everything but what ended up
happening is instead he was met with
this giant white void now at that point
he's met with the living embodiment of
eternity and this is not a normal
circumstances not supposed to happen and
here's the reason why
eternity is in and of itself the answer
to the question what if like all the
life in the universe everything that
represented all life could get up and
walk around
that would be eternity and so in a giant
white void when there is essentially
nothing eternity should not exist but
Doctor Strange exists therefore eternity
is a reflection of Doctor Strange
he's basically a reflection of existence
now you would think eternity would take
the form of Doctor Strange if that were
the case and if it chose to it could um
but eternity has its own form and that's
the reason why he appears the way he
does but what it asked Stephen strange
is what in the heck happened here and
the responses Stephen was to basically
say well the belief was that that
Galactus would be destroyed and one it
would be the end of him and a main
Marvel Universe and two it would bring
an end to all the magical threat that
exists out there and like all these
crazy magical dimensions where Galactus
was going nuts what we what eternity
ends up revealing this even strange is
that's not what happened instead what
took place is that what Stephen strange
did was essentially destroy the universe
and then reset it there's this tiny
little singularity at the very beginning
of everything - it's essentially like
it's frozen in a moment like it's frozen
in time for a second but what's
basically happening here is Stephen
strange Hickel act has destroyed
Galactus Galactus imploded sucked
everything in on self and basically gave
birth to like a new universe and so this
is kind of the moment before the
universe explodes in the Big Bang and
becomes something wholly new and that's
kind of a big deal because the question
that's asked here is how did that happen
right like how do we get to that point
where it ended up being like Doctor
Strange who reset everything and that's
what we end up or at least Doctor
Strange seems to indicate that it was
the intention of Mephisto right it was
the grand plan of Mephisto to
essentially reset all of reality but
then we end up finding out that's not
true it's not what my Vista wanted that
Mephisto is realm of hell resides on
souls right I mean we've talked about
that before but for those of you guys
who were new here Mephisto is kind of a
stand-in for Satan where at least he was
until al Ewing introduced the one below
olney credible whole comics but Mephisto
was kind of this being who would
basically trick people
well it's like he would come to you in a
time of meat in a time of dire and say I
can help you out of the situation I can
give you what you want all I'm going to
do is ask for something in return and if
you choose to barter with him two things
will happen
the first is that you'll get what you
want but then you'll get something that
handicaps it you'll say like man like
you I really wish I had like a million
dollars I mean I'm in desperate need of
like being able to pay off my house or
something along those lines
and so Mephisto would give you the money
to have your house paid off and then as
soon as your house was paid off if you
like destroyed it's torn and then the
other thing is when you die you'll take
your soul he's a pretty bad guy
having said that he's also supremely
powerful but like appearing here to
Steven strange and just being like you
screw everything up you destroyed
Galactus you screwed everything up this
fraction of a moment when Mephisto ended
up yanking dr. strange to his room
Mephisto is far more powerful than
Doctor Strange and that's the reason why
Steven strange doesn't really cause me
any beef with Mephisto right I mean
under any normal circumstances if
Mephisto had been away from his own
realm long enough like dr. strange could
start some stuff and so what is
happening is Mephisto kind of turns to
him and says well you know he starts to
think and he says well if you had the
ability to basically fix the universe
would you do it and dr. strange says yes
and this is important because dr.
strange had made a deal with Mephisto
he'd made a pact with him he would seek
help from a Fisto to free Umar and and
Clea who Mephisto had taken Leo and
Galactus was going crazy
dr. strange made a barter with Mephisto
that hey I'll come calling for a favor
later on and in return I will release
Clea and an Ummah at the moment so
that's what that's exactly my fist oh
did so this seems to basically be the
the requests being baby on the fist oh
is fix everything as it was kind of
crazy because when that happens Steven
strand says well I can't just do it
willy-nilly because there's judges out
there there's people that want to make
sure that the cosmic balance is being
maintained and that's when you're met by
the arrival of the Living Tribunal and
this is kind of a cool thing because
under normal circumstances the Living
Tribunal would probably look at this and
say I see no error here if I'd in terms
like what happened a conflict broke out
and a being attained and same amount of
power and with the destruction of that
being came the birth of a new universe
it's the natural order of things
and so the results of this is that the
Living Tribunal initially seeks to ask
Doctor Strange what's your motivation
behind this like are you going to
recreate the universe and then fancy
yourself a god or are you going to
recreate the universe as it was and of
course when he ends up saying is I'm
going to recreate it as it was and the
reason why is because if Stephen strange
decided to make himself a god like make
himself the god of the universe he would
stand side by side with eternity best
magical and balanced it's a mystical
imbalance
in the universe and the Living Tribunal
would never allow that to happen in the
exact same way that when Adam warlock
sought to become when he got the
Infinity Gauntlet at the end of the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and he
sought to rule alongside eternity that
the Living Tribunal said this is a
cosmic imbalance you cannot have two
absolute beings in the universe right
you can't have two supreme beings of the
universe it doesn't work that way you
could only have one and that's exactly
what the tribunal says you can do what
you want to do like you can fix the
universe just make sure that everything
goes back exactly the way that it was
before
and that's exactly what ends up
happening it's kind of a crazy thing
because what's basically going on here
is Stephen strange destroyed the
universe and then remade it and the
difference here is that he's remaking it
exactly the way that it was before now
the reality is is if I'm being honest
here it's not really a letdown for me
it's not really a disappointment for me
and the reason why is because what you
basically get is this this kind of is
it's really more like a focus on on
Stephen strange right like the price is
Stephen strange has to pay for for the
magic that he wields and then the role
he plays which is the biggest
undertaking he's ever seen basically
recreating all of existence now if this
was a big crossover event then I'd be
pissed I'd be mad because I'd be like
well this is just a lazy way to end it
it's just a really lazy way to end the
event but for me it's not really a lazy
way to end the story it's basically
saying that like Stephen strange is the
sorcerer supreme this is his job is his
job to do things like this and so to me
that's why it works because it's the
nature of his character I think it works
I think it fits in perfectly one of the
other cool things that comes out of this
is remember like when it comes to to the
universe it has to be made perfectly
which means necessity and so this
basically means the return of all these
dark beams Thanos mistress death like
all these terrible characters who have
existed over the years and done and and
committed heinous acts as it was kind of
a cool little moment because when that
happens you basically have him having to
like relive his life like relive all his
past mistakes the fact that he was he
was an amazing surgeon the fact that his
arrogance got the better of him that he
actually drove off a cliff he ended up
losing the ability to use his hands and
then he became the sorcerer supreme he
has to go back and relive all these
mistakes he made all these battles that
he fought and it be very very easy for
him to kind of go back and say well
maybe I didn't drive off a cliff or
maybe I my arrogance didn't get the
better of me or you know this maybe this
happened maybe that happens along those
lines I'm not gonna explain a man's life
a little bit better but the issue is who
knows what effect it will have on the
universe what he's basically doing here
because he's molding at any change he
makes will affect this universe it won't
create a branch off universe it will
affect the future of this universe and
so if he decided not to fly off the
bridge and if he does
and that he basically went on to
continue to become an amazing surgeon
then it could trade like this totally
bleak and dark future where everything
is ruled by Baron Mordo who knows what
kind of reality that would possess
instead what he does is he goes back to
this moment when you ended up having
Missoula's
show up and and basically initiate this
whole thing right because remember it
was Zola's who showed up after Galactus
had basically you know threatened his
planet or at least was believed to be on
the way to consume its planet and then
in turn like it was Doctor Strange being
a little hottie being a little arrogant
and then like Zola
taking off and then whisking Galactus
into the magical dimension that led to
all this in the first place and so what
he does is he has managed ham
enchantment spell Fonda's Olaf and
basically says like this is the nature
of the beast like you are now contained
and instead of being the person that
says like whoa sorry about your luck man
there's really nothing you could do you
know and kind of putting zola's in a
position to where he was desperate and
believe that he just had to get rid of
Galactus in order to make it work
instead Stephen strange reasons with him
and notice this this is actually kind of
a cool concept one of the things he says
here is he says that whenever it was a
Galactus showed up on earth that he was
always sent away but no two
circumstances ever worked the same now
that is true to a degree but the the
ultimate nullifier kind of flies in the
face of that by the ultimate nullifier
being this device that anything you
pointed out and pull the trigger on
it'll basically kind of wipe it from
existence as if it was never there in
the first place right and so but for the
most part they're right whenever
Galactus shows up and and tries to
consume the world it's always a
different reason for why he ends up
leaving and so that's basically what it
is that the Doctor Strange tells him is
he says there was one point work a lot
to show to a planet called Xen law and
basically consumed or at least was going
to consume the world until a guy named
Norrin Radd chose to become Galactus
Herald and instead he would basically
seek out worlds and Galactus would spare
his and so that's the statement that he
really makes - Zola's is this is really
the only option you have to basically
surrender yourself to become Galactus
his new Herald spear your world but go
forward helping him find other worlds
following his meeting with the Living
Tribunal and eternity both of whom
approve avoid of the work he's done the
fact that everything's back to normal
and it's essentially like nothing ever
happens at all he suddenly whisked away
by Mephisto and this is when we get to
like the really duplicitous side of
Mephisto right because what he says is
no no no you still owe me a favor and
when Stephen strain says yeah but I
remade the universe just like you asked
me Fisto says I never actually asked you
to do that I never actually made that a
request I simply presented the situation
to you and that's how Mephisto works you
have to be very meticulous in terms of
what
he says and how he says it and no point
in his dealings with dr. strange did he
say then I'm asking you to read to fix
the universe I'm asking you to set
everything back to the way that it was
before he never did that you know
because that um it's kind of interesting
Mark Waid sort of yanked the spider man
one more day chained in this scenario uh
what he basically says is I want a
fraction of a soul like I want a
fraction of a soul that exists out there
and so it's kind of crazy because well
we're not really explicitly told what it
is what it seems to be is a fraction of
clea soul right like the ex-wife of
Stephen strange because when he shows up
there he basically asked her like do you
believe there's a chance for us to start
over do you believe there's a chance for
us to find romantic happiness once again
and Clea is like absolutely I do I've
always thought about that why are you
asking me and he's like because I was
hoping you would give me a different
answer and then basically that's her
mind like wipes away her memories of him
she has no idea who Stephen strange is
now in reality if you're not a fan of
Stephen strange this moment will pass
without any real measure of value you're
just gonna be like okay I mean I guess
that's the thing but if you are fan of
Stephen strange I don't know how you'll
take it whether you'll be mad or whether
you'll be happy I honestly don't really
care Clea never really interested me
that much in the first place but it is
kind of interesting I imagine for a
hardcore Doctor Strange fans this is
like a Spider Man one more day kind of
thing um just not as is you know as
impactful or as big because Doctor
Strange is in spider-man but still you
know it's it's kind of an interesting
moment because it's basically Doctor
Strange going back to the path of being
alone going back to the passages of it
just being him and nobody else is
intriguing here it's really really
interesting but with that being said
guys we're gonna be in this video to an
end if you are new here to come as
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you